you know when we talk about the
transatlantic slave trade and how much
autonomy was lost we're talking about
freedom over your body freedom over your
language freedom over your thinking over
your religion your spirituality like
everything everything was stripped taken
away from lands that you knew and
stretch so far away from them that
there's no way to return so when you
mention trauma there were rules against
right you could be killed for teaching
an enslaved black person how to read and
read what we're trying to do now is
educate ourselves right and she's had a
really another really profound thing
later in our in our conversation she
said we were fighting for equal access
to education when we should have been
fighting for equal access to
neighborhoods hmm because where you live
and it's still the case where you live
dictates how well how well your school
how good your school is tips on your
life outcomes everything right it's
crazy
someone's opinion may contradict yours
where's my friend Allen it's all about
your perspective who are we and what is
the nature of this reality
[Music]
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sake on we are still
on site at the American Anthropological
Association Annual Meeting in Vancouver
British Columbia we are now going to be
speaking with dr. rachet Daniel Barnes
piracy hi how are you Ally thanks for
coming out thank you for having me
we're so pumped for this comedy I'm
super excited and before we get into all
of your incredible work you're an
award-winning author you are also the
Dean of Pearson college yes at Yale
University yes
we're gonna get into all this good stuff
I'm very excited for it prior to that I
want to ask you some of our questions
that were obsessed about and we ask all
of our guests about do you feel like
we're all one as in like the human body
community or like even outside of that
like even nature and that is all that is
I definitely think that there's a you
know not to be hokey but you know the
whole Lion King idea of the circle of
life I definitely think that there's a
way in which we're all connected I don't
know that I would say that we're all one
but I do think that we're all connected
and I think that if we I think that if
we were more attentive to all of those
connections we would satisfy a lot of
the problems with our with our
communities and challenges with our
climate and our earth and conflicts and
a lot of stuff yeah that's a perfect
lead-in to where we like going next
which is is the most upstream issue
that's causing all of the down
dream issues those feelings of
separation and that lack of feelings of
interconnectedness mm-hmm
yeah I agree with that definitely I but
I often define myself as a communal
person and and so I think that you know
there are definitely ways in which we
operate in the world and it's not
everybody right there are some groups in
our in our world who understand our
interconnectedness and and behave
accordingly and then there are others
who are very much more individualistic
and think that you know whatever they do
you has very little to do with anyone
else and so yeah I think we definitely
have some issues with not understanding
how interconnected we are what would be
a principle that you could recommend we
look at things like indigeneity and we
look at modernity and we look at what we
could potentially do to harmonize these
two and a best directional possibility
moving forward what are some of the
principles that you've experienced
yourself that have helped people with
those feelings of interconnectedness
that's really tough Alan
I mean I guess on a very you know if I
think about things like embodiment which
is something that we're really starting
to pay more attention to you even in my
field of anthropology when I think about
things that are that are naturally
occurring that make us connect more
authentically with our interconnectivity
it's it's things like music and dance
whenever I see people allowing
themselves to be moved by music and and
movement I see that interconnectedness
and and I think you know I think
sometimes it's you know we get to a
point I think in our you know our
process of moving through our life
stages and our life cycles of thinking
that we're not supposed to move as much
we're not supposed to dance so we're not
supposed to you know I there's a saying
that says dance light as if no one's
watching and and that's what happens
right that as we get older we care and
we lose some of that natural ability to
to be to be interconnected right and
I've seen you know I'm traveling with my
mom and my grandma through the
conference and I've seen you know we the
three generations approach life
differently
because we're in three different life
stages and one more with your kid and
one more with my yeah my daughter was
gonna come and she wasn't able to
because she can't get away from classes
so we would have had four generations
here in different stages of life and I
see I've you know obviously I've known
my grandmother since I was born and
she's she's 91 now and when I see the
way that she interacts with the world
[Music]
it's very different
you know from say my daughter and
she's you know gotten to this point in
her life stage where she doesn't she's
not concerned about what people think
about her right she she moves through
the world with generosity and
graciousness but it's very and I
shouldn't say but and it's very much
just living right just you know trying
to live and so even her coming to
Vancouver was about her you know trying
to live holy fully right I'm travelling
from Philadelphia today in Cooper so I
think you know I was bringing that up to
say that the this issue of you know
caring about what other people think I
think sometimes keeps us from being able
to make the connections and approach one
another as if we are interconnected
there's so much you know hierarchy and
politics and you know stages steps what
you're supposed to do when how with whom
that I think interrupts our ability to
really be in community with one another
yes every child is an artist every child
is wants to dance and unleash themselves
and we want to keep that through
adulthood the artist and the dancer and
unleashing our gifts into the world and
to architect a social fabric that's
conducive for that rather than at times
feeling like it's choking economic
machinery choking the creativity so
there's that and and a level of
grandmother that's seen the world since
like 1930 you've seen what's happened
and then being able to get behind the
perspective and know how to
how what would it what is it what is it
gonna feel like in in 40 50 60 years
just you know gliding through as an
older person through the world and I
wanna also take the interconnectedness
to even such a thing that is with us all
the time which is the breath mmm every
breath in comes from phytoplankton to
trees every bite of the Apple comes from
the power of the Sun there is no
separation your words are changing my
physiology and my neural architecture
and as you talk there's just there's no
disconnection and to view it in that way
and to teach children that from birth is
seems to be a very indigenous principle
and modernity when the children are born
into metropolis is there's light
pollution you exchange a sheet of paper
for the Apple don't grow food ever so
you get these disconnections that that
happen and so it does really seem like
the intertwining of these worlds and
bringing the best from them and moving
forward is gonna be paramount yeah I
also want to see if you have an idea of
the purpose of this reality of what
we're living now yes
[Music]
I I would have to say that I that so you
know so I'm hesitating because my my my
own understanding of my relationship
with a higher power has to do with would
answer that question from the
perspective of you know from my from my
upbringing which is about Christianity
and about thinking through the purpose
for being here as one that is about
living through living out of purpose
living out our own purpose and and
finding out and only knowing what that
purpose is by by being connected to that
higher power so I feel like the purpose
for all of us to be here the purpose for
this world at all has something to do
with what the higher power sees as our
purpose which I don't know we were
briefly talking about this before we
started but it is that all of these
since the dawn of time all of these
teachings and feelings of the
interconnectedness the unconditional
love the higher power all these types of
feelings the one the unity the source
the Big Bang the universe would everyone
call it are all pointing up the mountain
from different perspectives and it's
very pluralistic coexisting no problem
but even that to harmonize together on
this grand project that is being played
out called
Earth called this big at times it feels
like it is a big learning simulation
that we're all a part of that word we're
helping it it the one become more alive
understand itself better through this
game that we're playing that in the
deepest levels of interconnectedness and
so this is a big challenge it feels like
this is a big challenge
will we be able to rise to the occasion
to understand the interconnectedness and
to build the next world that has a more
conducive social fabric for flourishing
and that's what our like one of the main
principles is of the program is
inspiring people to realize that next
world and to all cohesively push for it
and build it because in doing so we can
fulfil the ultimate pinnacle paramount
destiny of what could be mm-hmm and
that's what puts the smile on the faces
of us all that's how that's how I it's
been fun to interpret the reality mm-hmm
yeah so so it sounds like you think our
purpose is to be interconnected and have
this kind of cohesiveness that is yeah
that that makes sense and also
individually to be able to express our
gifts into the world and make it a good
social fabric to make it fun for people
to do so right so those two things again
it's kind of like an individualism
collectivism marriage as well yeah
there's a yeah there's a you have your
own responsibility to live out your your
own purpose that but that should be
working in you know working in community
with everyone else's yeah yes so take us
I want you to take us through a macro
level understanding of kind of what has
been unfolding because we this really
has to go back to probably somewhere
around like the 500 or so years ago of
just a process of beginning to go and
colonize from from Europe towards the
rest of the world and then
having things like the transatlantic
slave trade happen and then having just
just August honestly put there is a lot
of trauma that needs to be healed and we
need to grow through that and
collectively evolve and and be honest
and loving and caring about all of that
process so that has that has created a
lot of complexity in our world helped us
see it on the macro level of what you've
been doing as an anthropologist mm-hmm
and you mean the in terms of the history
of that or or in terms of and what it
brought forth the history of didn't
would have brought forth I mean I think
it's important for us to note that we
don't get modernity without the
transatlantic slave trade and so and so
so many things had to be happening at
the same time for that or not at the
same time I mean it happened over time
right we talked about the transatlantic
slave trade as if it was like you know
one blip in time but it took a really
long time to to manifest itself in the
way that it eventually did right that
you know that when we talk when we say
the transatlantic slave trade we're
talking about you know a 300 year period
that went through you know herbs and
flows of you know how people were going
to be moved and what communities were
going to be affected both in Europe and
in Africa and outside and even the
indigenous communities that were
affected in the Americas you know by
this transatlantic slave trade that that
also you know often are not part of the
conversation so you know a macro view
you know if I mean I guess you're asking
if we're thinking about it in terms of
you know how these how this
interconnectedness may be got got
challenged got broken down
is that where we're headed yeah wolf
yeah where did where did the thought
come that one can own someone else yeah
so so that already existed right so
historically slavery existed long before
the transatlantic slave trade but it was
done differently so you know people were
enslaved in various parts of the world
because of wars or because of debts or
because of you know I mean it's always
been about resources and in territories
and so I can't even tell you when that
started I mean that's in all of the
ancient tax rate that people were
involved in slavery in some way but it's
not until the transatlantic slave trade
that we have a moment where people are
no longer being seen as people because
even sort yeah because even when you
were enslaved in previous periods you
you know you were you were in a lower
caste so to speak but you could marry
out of it your children weren't trapped
into it and so you know there were there
was freedom even in in the enslavement
and that was not so during the
transatlantic slave trade right that
that freedom freedom ended right there
was no more freedom over over any part
of yourself right of your war nothing no
nothing right not even your language
right which is something that I talk
with my students about even in terms of
the way that colonization took took hold
at the same time as the Chinese
transatlantic slave trade right so that
so that European nations were coming in
to various places and saying okay no
more your language right our language is
the one that you need to know and then
when you need to speak and so I've
actually had students say to me that
speaking in in a mostly European tongue
that is
- they're indigenous tongue is a type of
enslavement in and of itself because
being being able to express yourself in
your language is often very different
from expressing yourself in another
language right the translation isn't
exact the emotion the embodiment right
it's not it's not exact and so it feels
like losing parts of yourself so I bring
that up to say you know when we talk
about the transatlantic slave trade and
how much autonomy was lost we're talking
about freedom over your body freedom
over your language freedom over your
thinking over your religion your
spirituality like everything everything
was stripped taken away from lands that
you knew and stretch so far away from
them that there's no way to return right
so when you mentioned trauma right
that's one of the things that I'm I know
we were gonna talk about some of my
current projects but but my my off in
the distance project is about health and
disparities disparities in health for
black women who I think I'm not a
medical anthropologist but just some of
the work that I've been reading by
people like fleet amassed Jackson Leaf
mullings
donna iand vez these are people who have
been doing work in in reproduction care
bridges have been doing work in
reproductive health for black women and
starting to theorize the effects on the
effect of this trauma on black women's
bodies over time right that you can't
actually see everybody's moving through
the world it seems quite well but then
when it's time for you know for first
things that seem very basic to happen
you know things like childbirth and
delivery these things become complicated
be and we're starting to think
it has a you know biomedical source so
so really starting to think through how
these traumas you know because we can
talk about these traumas as being passed
down by a cultural memory but we know
that our bodies have memory as well so
yeah all of that yeah my goodness
yeah when you're giving me this this
visual of kind of a cultural lineage
that was experienced by peoples and then
when it's completely transplanted I mean
it's all stripped away it's all stripped
away I mean it's every component
spiritual mental physical emotional
well-being language I mean it's all just
stripped food music right all this stuff
and then it's yeah that's the real like
way to I guess awaken to what it would
be like to you know forbid just if we
really need something as egregious as a
VR experience of being trapped in a dark
ass boat and chained next to a bunch of
other people for people to empathize and
realize and heal the trauma but it's
without doubt I mean it's all so
interconnected that when you have
something like it for me it's like this
big red gaping wound in the Atlantic
that's what it like feels like and then
it's symptoms out with its flowering
into all other types of issues that we
have yeah and I think I mean I do want
to be I do want to be clear that that
there was an attempt to strip everything
away right but we were able to retain
some things and so you know despite lots
of best efforts she's to strip it away
right to strip away all language all
culture all spirituality we know
especially as anthropologist
and especially in the black
anthropological tradition we know that
many many things were retained and and
because people resisted right people
were interested in finding ways to to to
keep to keep themselves right to keep
some sense of that autonomy and there
are a lot of ways in which that has been
passed down also right and you know we
can see it in even and you know a lot of
American music there's there's there are
musical traditions that have been been
retained familial practices that have
been retained preparations of foods that
have been retained even foods themselves
because many of them were brought from
the West African coast and planted in
the Americas and then people were
brought to tend them so you know some of
the foods and the ways that they're
prepared have been retained so I you
know I think there's there's a there is
a lot of trauma but one of the things I
talk to my students about a lot is that
the story isn't all all all that mostly
bad super bad very traumatic horrible
but we've been people who and people's
right who have been resilient as well
yeah yeah it becomes our collective
responsibility to awaken ourselves to
the healing process that needs to happen
worldwide around these deepest issues
with migrations forced migrations
seeking zuv Asylum order conflicts
Warfare's over time harmonize towards
decreasing military industrial complex
budgets focusing more on childhood
education around the planet bringing
prosperity to all it's just it's so
mind-blowing buying a cup of coffee for
three dollars in modernity and then
realizing that
80% of the planet makes less than that
in a day and then looking at modernity
and realizing that so many of these
things like a transatlantic slave trade
was a catalyst of modernity being
truthful about that process and I'm
really happy that you also talked to
students about the importance of what
was the perseverance and what was the
grit and the retention of the cultural
Heritage's and lineages and how to
actually keep those I'm alive and
roaring yeah we were talking to Tiffany
Marquis Jones on the show as well
yeah about the retention of chocolate
city in DC through spoken word poetry
and art and that's a great way to
express oneself and keep lineages
roaring with light yeah
take us to then how raising the race
mhmmm black career women redefine
marriage motherhood and community this
is your award-winning book yes
how what was the thesis of it I have a
copy of it can I show it I would love to
put it right here on the side exactly
now that we have the copy next to us yes
give us the thesis yeah huh essentially
the book is taking a look at how and and
going back a little bit to what we were
talking about it just a few minutes ago
and that is how black communities black
families have responded to a lot of the
challenges to family life that have
happened even since slavery right so
recognizing that slavery did a lot to
disrupt black family life actually
disrupted black family life so even the
you know the movement from the continent
to the Americas was a disruption a break
because people were not brought here
with their families they were usually
taken stolen from their families
and once here made to produce workers
right so reproduction became a me
of production and those you know the
offspring that were made of that during
slavery were then enslaved right so
black women were forced to through their
reproduction continue to create people
who were going to be a means of
production and so what black families
have done though going back to this idea
of survival perseverance retention have
worked really really hard to preserve
some sense of family kinship care and
overtime that has fallen to primarily
women to mothers and so what what black
people in in America primarily the u.s.
south but there are other parts of the
Americas that have done the same have
created what we call a metro focal
family in response to the situation
which was that fathers often were not
present particularly in slavery rate
could be sold away or didn't know who
the father was or maybe the father was
the overseer or the master and so rate
no father present so mothers women
became who raised the children and took
care of the community as a whole and so
what I really talk about in the book is
while I'm talking about the contemporary
moment and how mothers black mothers are
responding to the challenges of
modernity in trying to raise their
children and have what is supposed to be
a model family they are leaning on a lot
of the traditions that they have learned
over time through their mothers
and the response has primarily been even
over time and what I come up with is a
concept that's called black strategic
mothering and the idea behind that is
over time black women have been having
to rethink the way that they interact
with essentially the world right the
workplace the relational parts of
themselves visa vie they're men visa vie
they're women visa vie they're mothers
grandmothers fathers they've had to
create these these responses that are
about the survival of their children
first and the community as a whole
because it's always been the case that
black women have never only been
responsible for their own biological
children they've always had to be
concerned for the children the community
of children right and so the book really
goes into this particular moment and how
black women who have acquired education
who have acquired means are at a
particularly interesting point in our
history where they have the ability to
make decisions about whether or not they
are going to be in the full-time work
place or or be at home moms and this is
a very new relatively new phenomenon
right there have been black women who
have worked from home historically there
were protective measures put in place
especially in the Jim Crow South because
having your having a black woman working
outside the home was pretty what could
be particularly dangerous especially if
she was working in the home of a white
family or at a white business she was
very vulnerable so there we have a
record of in a history of black women
working from home but this is a little
different this is I have the I have the
education
and the and the professional pedigree to
work outside the home in a professional
context but I am choosing to make some
different decisions about my
relationship with work because at this
particular moment I think it's very
important for me to be more responsive
to my children and my husband my partner
then to the workplace which used to be
the way that black women really focused
on uplifting the community because it
was because of the history of the
economic system in our country black
women were more likely to be gainfully
employed than black men even though they
were making less money they could keep
their jobs longer usually than black men
so being able to make a decision to
leave the workplace means that your
partner is able to sustain the household
which is new and you are able to
redirect your efforts away from a
communal look outward to one that is
more inward and focused on your own kids
now what's complicated about that is
that is that the black family unit has
always tried to be more of a collective
right black families have been looked to
as ones that were examples of how to do
childcare from a communal perspective
rather than a nuclear perspective right
so the challenge in this upward mobility
is that there's a turn away from the
communal and one that is more toward the
individual part of what I fear eyes in
the book is that these women are seeing
themselves even though they are turning
to an individual response it has a lot
to do with the neoliberal market there
they're turning to an individual
response but I argue that it's from a
communal perspective because what they
want to do is be
good representations of black families
right because the number of good black
families has been declining and how do
we define good well if we talk about
marriage and family many people think
about it as two - you know two parents
in there they're happy and the reason
the kids together and did it up right
and when I say to parents I mean lesbian
or gay or whatever the combination is
but two parents raising the kids and
keeping them you know safe and on track
and educated and so on and so forth so
it's a it's a really it's an interesting
time in our contemporary moment to think
about what kinds of responses people are
having to the lack of public supports
and and even employer supports right
that make it possible for people to be
able to to live out their purpose and be
and be in tune with their their kids
purpose right and make sure that those
things are going to be successfully
attained that was a long answer sorry it
was in the exact amount of okay let's go
through that so we had another way of
viewing what we were talking about prior
to that where you gave us an
understanding of this role of on top of
being moved to constrict away of that of
that culture being brought to that new
place that then there was this process
of making more humans for the process of
production being slaves for production
and then having the
the there's a maternal focus a matte
match a focal natural focal mm-hmm a
mattre focal process of raising children
yeah mattre focal and then over time
then there's obviously a tremendous
amount of changes that have happened
with but you know you give us the
example of you know wool women in
general post post-civil war post healing
for us at least the first parts of the
healing women beginning to you know
raise raised children at least in their
own homes women having the option of
getting the right to vote having the
option to go to the workforce and they
would like lots of time was spent at
home raising children for women and men
were able to earn enough money to
provide for the entire home mm-hmm
meanwhile nowadays median mill income is
like very stagnant
well GDP skyrocketing a lot of that
again 1% taking like 50 plus percent of
the actual new fruits that are emerging
so when we look at what is going on with
the movement towards nuclear families in
general mm-hmm is it then that women
entering into hierarchies can be for
careers can be both helpful for them
unleashing gifts into the world men
learning how to also nurture children
being extremely important and as
indigeneity was much of that so there's
a sort of communalism that was such a
vital part of the way that we harmonized
our communities which now has definitely
looked in turned into little like
suburban boxes on the hillsides and
little units stacked and skyscrapers on
top of each other and
that a big big question is you know in
this coming from the perspective of
African Americans is a perspective which
is one layer of identity Oh also from
the whole perspective of just in general
nuclear families going into the little
boxes on the hillside which is what are
we gonna do about the process of
everyone going into that mode of of and
how do we come how do we come into some
sort of a deeper cohesion with our
communities albeit it's like this is
such a different phenomena just feels so
different to me I've never felt studying
history with such vigor over time I've
never really seen something that was so
deeply nuclearized as it is and it just
it seems like when everyone is spending
all of their time in their nuclear
Styles a family with the devices and the
internet and the drone deliveries and
the virtual worlds and yeah and
everyone's buying their own goods for
that property itself I mean it's it's a
very it kind of also takes us to that
point of disconnection rather than
interconnection so is there also so is
there also like a proposal of sorts to
like you indicated it's also kind of
about showcasing like you know we are we
are a successful black family in the
United States yeah
and that's also very see it be it is
such an important modality here and we
were also learning that so I think
Washington DC that has the richest black
neighborhood and then Atlanta is the
second largest and if you just like look
what are what are some of the skills our
habits in those places are we retaining
community as we're also going to it's a
great question I think you know for some
of the families that I interviewed yes
people are even though they're they're
turning their focus towards their
nuclear you know they're they're wanting
to make sure that their kid
they're safe right because there's
especially for black parents there's a
lot of precarity around making sure kids
or their kids are fine right and we
could probably talk for a whole nother
hour about why that's the source of
precarity for black families
particularly even black middle-class
families right like you like people
expect that you know black families that
are better in low-income situations
precarity makes sense right there's
probably a lot of stuff for you to be
concerned about right but for black
middle-class families who think that
they're moving from those spaces into
you know these suburban boxes these you
know high-rise boxes they think they're
creating some degree of safety are
finding that that safety isn't
necessarily there or it's elusive or
they still have to put up some you know
some mechanisms to make sure that that
they have some degree of control over
that and what they what they find is
that is that the way what these women
found was that the way that they could
ensure some degree of that safety what
they felt was they needed to pay more
attention at home right but that didn't
mean that they didn't want to also be
connected to the community so many of
them while being very focused on their
own nuclear families were also being
very intentional about being in the
suburban you know boxes with other
people so that they could find a
community with those people so there
were a couple of families that I
highlight in the book who intentionally
moved in a particular neighborhood
because they knew that that neighborhood
had people that they already knew that
they could do family meals together that
they could you know have their kids do
swimming lessons together at the
community pool right so there are ways
in which that they were saying okay
we're when nuclear focus were inward
focus but we're going to find ways to
still build and be in community right
still very involved in their churches
still very involved in communal
organizations that are about you know
volunteering or
doing things in in other parts of the
black community right now it's still
complicated I don't mean to say that
this you know fixes everything
but there are ways in which
interconnectivity is still intentional
right they're still thinking about it
from that perspective even as they are
creating these more nuclear family forms
that are less about the metric vocality
and more about the the nuclear yeah yeah
this seems to be something that could
potentially be applied to urbanization
just in general and metropolis is in
general as we move into more of the
nuclear family
esque behaviors to do things like create
more communal activity and yeah yeah I
really I really like the ones you listed
breaking bread together doing things
like swimming other communal activities
of learning and experiencing together
yeah yeah keeping memories together yeah
yeah there was one woman who talked
about how she'd grown up in New Orleans
on a street with you know you know not a
lot of means like the people in her
community didn't have a lot of means and
and you know there were like there's
like two streets where all the kids knew
each other and they all played together
and her in her upbringing and she said
you know when she was looking for a
community to raise her family and she
was looking for how to recreate that and
because she wanted her kids to grow up
in that kind of that kind of relational
space right where they were you know
they were they weren't locked away in
their suburban house but they were out
you know playing and meeting the other
kids in the neighborhood and stuff like
that but you know the my my current
project is looking at how black women
are making decisions about school and
part of the reason school choice and
part of the reason why I'm I'm on that
subject now is because of the women in
my book who were saying that just kind
of jumping off for what you were what we
were talking about just before that
those the schools are are a point of
contingent for for many family
um because education is such an upstream
[Music]
yeah
and who's who's educating I mean my
session for the panel my session for the
conference this year was a panel on with
with black women who were talking about
the research that they're doing about
black education and black schools and we
had significant for dr. signifi afford
um who wrote two books about black kids
and schooling and she she talked about
you know she made a very good point as
we were getting started in the in the
panel and she said you know we have to
differentiate between conversations
about education conversations about
schooling schooling has always been a
place of contention for for black kids
and black families because basically
they weren't designed for us we weren't
ever supposed to be educated right we
weren't ever so knowing there were rules
against right you could be killed for
teaching an enslaved black person how to
read and write right so she's like you
know it was was never we were never
intended right what we're trying to do
now is educate ourselves right and she's
had a really another really profound
thing later in our in our conversation
she said we were fighting for equal
access to education when we should have
been fighting for equal access to
neighborhoods mmm because where you live
and it's still the case where you live
dictates how well how well your school
how good your school is your life
everything right it's crazy so so that's
where I am now in the in the new project
is looking at how moms in particular are
navigating those spaces right trying to
get their kids the you know a good
education good education yeah and what
that means yes yes and I really
appreciate these added profound aspects
to school choice such such an upstream
as we were discussing the very beginning
is the education of the child towards
that interconnectedness that
unconditional love doing project-based
learning around the sustainable
development goals healing traumas all
this kind of stuff pursuing their
Northstars etc yes we all have it and to
unleash it yeah and what that would do
for our world and then you give what you
gave us all these added perspectives to
it which is that it's fighting for
schooling versus fighting for zip codes
rend what that could have done or also
just education in general is a whole
suite of other things especially given
the newest forms of technology that
exist one can spend a lot of their time
educating themselves even outside of the
school system right and then how do we
then do things like make it so that no
matter really hopefully wherever you are
in the world that you gain access to the
highest level of democratized knowledge
possible where you yourself can kind of
have a an ala carte buffet of options
for you to pick what most feels like
your Northstar keep going in that
direction and educate yourself along
with you know mentors community other
kids but oh you gave that example to is
also so true that you how can one you
know if you go through an experience
where you do make so many good young
friends you're playing in the streets
and all stuff but then you have children
yourself and you're like how do I find a
pocket of these boxes where it seems
like there's actually community for my
kids to get raised in yeah yeah we have
a lot of challenges um-huh where do I
start
redirect me where do I start I mean the
meshed of the marriage of kind of your
book Plus school choice it totally makes
sense it's like these are what we want
to propose now on the social fabric
redesigns is again just like can we look
at things in such a multivariate way
where we can propose yes the information
technology wave this year so we do want
to democratize it yes but then there's
also the whole zip code schooling
thing is still existing yes so how do we
decrease obstacles and decrease tensions
increase community spaces yeah these are
great questions and things that I think
about a lot because my new project is
rooted in a neighborhood that is
connected to a neighborhood school both
have been declining over the last twenty
years and and so what I've been trying
to think about is is these are these are
communities right and community that the
folks in these communities want good
schools right and they want nice
communities right everybody wants the
same things everybody wants to grow up
in a in a nice environment safe
environment where they can educate their
kids and know that their kids are safe
and taken care of and loved and and and
and so when we think about how to marry
the access right so much technology we
have access we can we could design you
know we could come up with a with a
Scylla worldwide syllabus rate that
would that could you know be on the on
the internet and you could click on the
text and they you could go right to them
and and educate yourself I think that
and but at the same time we can't be so
dependent on technology that we don't go
outside and connect with our communities
right and I I think that there is room
for and definitely there is room for a
model that allows us to do both right I
think what I'm challenged by is there's
so much available video technology I
don't think our kids know how to
scaffold mmm they don't know what to pay
attention to they don't know what's a
good source and what's not for this that
was a really good way to put it if you
haven't
if you've discovered at least part of
what your Northstar may be how do you be
in scaffolding what you learn so it's
like having a meta perspective on your
learning
to get towards that yeah that's like
scaffolding thank you yeah and so and so
that's the thing right it's a it's the
reason you know my husband is an
educator and he says all the time that
we're gonna get to a point where we
don't need teachers he's a teacher he's
a high school teacher and he says we're
getting to it we're gonna get to a point
where they're they're gonna think they
don't need us anymore that they can you
know stick a computer on a robot and you
know the robot talks and the kids learn
and my coaches yeah yeah and then you
know maybe and he's you know he says
maybe the elite will be the ones you
have because they always have will have
tutors that you know that that work
didn't worked in and tandem with the
with the robots the AIS
I think there's probably some degree of
unfortunately truths as to what he's
what he's thinking about and guessing at
and that that that I honestly that
scares me and I usually tell him no no
no weird no they'll never get rid of
teachers teachers are so necessary but
when we look at the way that teachers
are treated and the ways in which
teachers are being replaced by spy well
really well educated vetted teachers who
teach well are being they are being
replaced by much younger not as
experienced not as well vetted just out
of college young people who are very
earnest in their desire to to to help
and to teach even but the fact that they
are you know in some ways being used as
a as an army of of able to be and able
to be able to be paid less
and move into these spaces with tech
says to me that my husband might be
right that because it'll be way easier
to replace them right with ya right and
it's so interesting so they like
technophiles people that are like
well-trained in technology that also
will be that are accepting less pay
which teachers should be paid incredibly
well but the more tenure teachers are
being paid a little bit better and so
there yet yes then as the the whole area
of where humans are able to complete
tasks better than AI is actually really
rapidly decreasing yes just in general
yes so we have to figure out what to do
and a universal basic ownership in our
future world is going to be crucial as
the emerging technology sub markets come
from we democratize the fruits of those
markets and text to the rest of the
planet yes so there's inclusive stake
holding weight rather than some sort of
a speciation on socioeconomic status
which everybody in the back of their
mind truly knows as possible yeah and we
and we are trying to mitigate that by
having no billionaires and governments
and corporations around the world can
you really deeply connect to your hearts
can you connect to unconditional love
and interconnectedness with the
environment with other humans and try
and really see the next world where it
could be that everyone's unique gifts
are brought forth and that there is no
dystopian crap that happens but it's
only figuring out how to keep building
the next best world's moving forward
yeah that's I'm just so like wanting to
help us focus our directional arrow over
there yeah because the I mean you can
even sell the story about the asteroid
hitting the planet or you can sell the
story about exploration and trying to
have billions of more people that get to
endeavor into consciousness and be
creative and feel love and
interconnection
and bring gifts forth into the world and
that's why we should go to other
celestial bodies and there's all these
different ways to tell the story in
telling it in the direction of yeah
there will be benefits to an AI teacher
I mean having a whole corpus of
Biotechnology when you yourself are
trying to learn about the inner workings
of a cell at the level that it
who knows rather than the limited
capacity of a three-pound brain knows is
it's helpful at times but to have
something that has a spirit something
that deeply has a socio-emotional
capacity to engage and that is still
gonna be part of the equation we foresee
for a while but then there's still that
question mark and when we do how do we
have discourse around that yeah yeah and
who and I think the thing for me too is
who gets to decide what that a I was
teaching the inner workings of a cell is
a little bit like easier that's for sure
easier than something like history right
yeah that one's oh yeah because there's
a tremendous amount of biases right and
who programs wait which we already know
right we already knows privacy's yeah
they we already know that I mean I just
saw Twitter on my Twitter feed that that
there's some tech that they're running
right now I can't remember the source
but there's some tech but they're
running that right now that that is
meant to read passports and can't pick
up darker skin tones mm-hmm who program
that not someone with a dark skin tone
because if you look at yeah a corpus of
images and you don't see any darker skin
tones and you're gonna know that it's
not gonna be able to read the darker
skin tones yeah so yes so this is a lot
of this is really again it comes to
inclusive stakeholder inclusive fitness
just in general um you know having
people at the at the table of deciding
on where we're going that represent a
very unique array of
of perspectives about the future of our
world especially the most people that
have studied philosophy ethics morals
the most spirituality the most in a
cohesion with people that have studied
science and anthropology engineering
design all these different fields kind
of can you know harmonizing for the next
because if we choose to so see the next
world as one that is filled with peace
harmony abundance and we can like you
said earlier scaffold our way to it and
sell that story to get to it that I feel
is most prosperous prosperity oriented
and less so when we looked at other
stories I I your point about what is
actually within that AI coach and what
it's teaching is really important to how
it's not biased how it's um yeah I'm
really happy that this back and forth
has taken us to also not only in within
such depths of interconnectedness in
history but then also to modernity and
future around what we're doing the
Dunbar number is really interesting and
there's a lot of projects around little
communities of like 150 or so people and
and having the growth of food and water
cycle processes there Andy and the
communal processes they're an
educational process I think that's also
very interesting component to this
equation yeah that vital people are I
think people are are experimenting with
that I know there's a there's a
community south of Atlanta that is
experimenting with you know having these
communities where people are growing
food it's not cohousing but it's similar
where people are growing food and
they're and they're you know they're
they're doing things you know more
locally right and they're locally
sourcing things and they're and it's
also available to the out you know
outside you know people who don't live
there but the the thing that that
concern that concerns me about how even
that space is being actualized is is
it's expensive it's expensive to live
there and so it's you know so so also
there's this thing of you know even in
creating these new these alternatives
that are that are getting us closer to
the collective collective the
interconnectedness often they come at a
premium right they just they're not
happening you know kind of organically
you know it's someone saying okay we're
gonna buy all this land and we're gonna
you know we're gonna have you know we're
gonna build housing and it's gonna be a
different price points but it's still
gonna be you know Xfinity a cost
prohibitive right for a lot of families
who that could benefit from that and it
seems like you know we every time my
husband he's um trained as a city
planner and engineer and and every time
we go into you know one of these older
cities that was you know designed
hundreds of years ago he's like we
already knew how to do this why why why
are we creating these space we already
know how to live together right we
already know that you know you have the
this you know housing
that is designed for multiple families
and you have green spaces that are
designed for you know being in community
and being outdoors and planting and and
yet we we go off and make gated
communities and then we make shopping
centers and put lots of parking out
front and it's like yeah Cities 2.0 the
future of cities feels with like a mix
between the indigeneity and modernity
and it feels more like it embeds the
interconnectedness and the unconditional
love in the communities and the more
holistic systems of food growth and
water cycling and energy cycling and
this is this is really great that we're
getting to I want to I want to ask you
one more final question that we asked on
the program what do you think is most
beautiful as a thing or just anything
most beautiful is is it's going to sound
hokey but love and what I mean by love
is is is how its manifested and in care
yeah
care I think and generosity of spirit
yeah that's what's most beautiful to me
love manifested and caring generosity of
spirit yeah which feels like it is one
of the main achievements that we can
have when we find ourselves in this
reality how can we bring that best yeah
absolutely
that is the most that selflessness
brings us the most highest feeling
yeah that's what I know that I strive
for in to receive and to give yep yes
which we receive every breath and give
every breath thank you this is a great
conversation we appreciate you thank you
thanks Riley great work thanks everyone
for tuning in and greatly appreciated
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking also check out
the links in the bio below to rachets
profile also her book page check that
out also check out her LinkedIn and
Twitter profiles check those on the bye
below also support the American
Anthropological Association you can find
their links in the bio below support
them you can support the other artists
entrepreneurs spiritual leaders
organizations in your communities that
you believe in and around the world you
can support our show our links are in
the bio below help us pay palpate
patreon cryptocurrency you can join us
design cool merch and get paid help us
continue doing cool things like coming
on site to epic conferences like Triple
A and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
let's build that next world together
scaffold our way to thank you very much
thanks for tuning in we'll see you soon
thank you thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]